[Music]
michael
is in alaska hey michael welcome to the
ramsey show
thank you it's pleasure to be talking to
you you too
what's up hey so i just got a quick
question i got a little bit of consumer
debt
and i own a home so i got a little bit
of equity
um what are your thoughts on possibly
taking out
a heloc or equity loan to
pay off that consumer debt bring down
the apr
and stuff like that and then just throw
that
equity loan into my
debt snowball i wouldn't
okay you want to know why why
because you're going to feel like you
did something and you didn't do anything
all you did was remove it now listen all
you did was move it
interest rates not your problem lack of
a budget lack of focus lack of attacking
this is your problem
you need to get fired up and pissed off
about being in debt
okay and get after your debt list it
smallest to largest pay minimum payments
on everything but the little one
and get after it because here the
problem when people move debt around
they use words like pay it off you
didn't pay it off
you moved it and two percent savings on
the interest rate is not your issue
your issue is getting focused getting on
a budget living on beans and rice
selling as much stuff the kids think
they're next get fired up and wired up
baby
that's what does it that's what moves
the needle
can we there's so much of what you teach
about
jobs and what we teach here that is
about action
it's um motive
which leads to motivation yes personal
finance is 80
behavior it's only 20 head knowledge
there's so much about a job
or choosing a career stepping into
something that is about
um you know don't try to trick it
to don't try to trick your way past the
hard work there's no shortcut to any
place that's worth going beverly seals
used to say
he's absolutely right and so why are you
going after it you've got to remind
yourself on the journey
why am i doing this i get that it takes
time you know if you walked out on the
street today with a camera and a
microphone and you asked people
are you willing to do whatever it takes
to get where you want to go
whether it be career and your money most
people look at you and instantly say
absolutely but if i followed up when i
said well but i think they mean that but
then here's the follow-up question if i
said are you willing to wait as long as
it takes
oh that's exactly what happens they
literally can respond that way and
here's why
there's something about the human
condition where we want everything now
that's what this journey is all
about it's what dave talks about all the
time it is it is
the budget helps you control the
behavior issued where you go hey
this is a long slog it's going to take
time and so you have to whether it's in
your career and doing work that you
deeply want to do because you know you
were put on this planet to do it
or it's paying off debt uh and saving
money so that you can live like no one
else
all of this is the same exact
conversation you want to live like no
one else you want to work like no one
else
it's going to take time and you better
have the big picture in mind
and know that this is a climb but it is
going to be worth it when i get there
there's no shortcut
there is not a shortcut a generation ago
there was
one of the world's best golfers was a
guy named gary player yes
and the story's been told about him over
and over and over again through the
years that
he was warming up at a tournament on the
driving range
and he's you know pulling back that
driver and sailing that ball out there
300 360 350 yards whatever
just popping that drive straight as a
string
and this guy walks up behind him goes i
would give anything to hit a golf ball
like that
and i think i think he caught him at the
wrong moment because he turned around
said no you wouldn't yeah
it's a fantastic story no you wouldn't
yeah you would not stand out here in the
heat
and hit 2 000 golf balls hit golf balls
so long that you get blisters
hit golf balls so long that the blisters
bus hit but golf ball so long that you
can't hold the golf club anymore from
the busted blisters you tape up your
hands and you hit another thousand balls
you wouldn't do that yeah that's right
you wouldn't do anything
to hit a golf ball like that to which
the poor guy just said i'm sorry i asked
you but
you know but just you know yeah that's
the thing you know i i would do
no you wouldn't you got you got to be
willing to do it and and so
that's the thing and i'm not picking on
michael here that's not the issue but
the issue is
there's a thing about uh action and
paying the price live like no one else
so that later you can live like no one
else
that supersedes a little bit of interest
saved by moving into a healer so true
88 of the people that move their debt
over for debt consolidation
go further into debt don't get out of
debt yeah 9 out of 10 times
yeah it's interesting they don't change
their habits that put them in there in
the first place that's right
they feel like they did something and
that's
dangerous to feel like you did something
when you did nothing yeah
you know there's a theme here we're
talking about folks that dave just
brought up
you've got to be passionate about
getting out of debt that gazelle
intensity where's that come from
about the next job you've got to be
passionate about doing work that you
were created to do to help people
so what's funny is you do a word
exercise and there's a german word
and there's also a greek word the root
word of passion means to suffer
now here's the deal when it's rice and
beans beans and rice
gazelle intensity working three or four
jobs the last couple times i've been on
the show we've had single moms
back to back shows who paid off an
enormous amount of debt
with multiple kids doing everything that
is suffering
to suffer that means these people know
what the word passion folks we gotta get
this isn't like some
romantic motivational poster word
this is i am willing to suffer
to go through pain and withhold pleasure
that's what that means in order to get
an outcome that i desire
greatly whether it's starting a business
inventing a product or service
getting out of debt losing weight
changing your relationships your
marriage
i'm going to tell you something passion
you got to be willing to suffer for that
outcome
there you go this is the ramsay show